first shanghai now beijing the capital
city of china with more than 20 million
people faces a potential city-wide
lockdown as covet cases grow some
apartment blocks have been quarantined
some subway stations closed and
restaurants are only doing takeout now
residents are on edge given what they
know happened in shanghai with its
extended lockdowns and people going
hungry beijingers fear they could be
next
china is scrambling to eradicate an
omicron outbreak in beijing
among the weapons in the city's arsenal
mass testing
residents are required to prove their
covert status three times a week
the government hopes this will allow
them to detect and isolate cases
immediately
for now things appear calm
but concerns are
growing i'm worried about the situation
but i can't do anything about it
i just wonder how long it's going to go
on
and what the economic consequences will
be
residents are still allowed to go out in
many districts
but a lot of activity has been wound
down
with tourist sites and other public
spaces closed
authorities are taking an incremental
approach
first locking down individual buildings
then expanding the measures to whole
neighborhoods if the virus spreads
this is all in line with china's zero
covert strategy
many subway stations and bus routes were
closed on wednesday
in-person classes at many of beijing
schools have also been suspended for at
least a week
city authorities are keen to show that
they have a handle on the situation
there are still some hidden sources of
sporadic covid19 infections at the
community level across beijing
we need to speed up screening tighten
controls prevent virus spillover between
districts to stem the spread of the
epidemic
they're also working to avoid the kind
of lockdown imposed in shanghai that has
seen millions sealed in their homes
often without enough to eat and has
created negative headlines across the
globe
restrictions are easing in some parts of
shanghai as cases drop
but some fear it's only a matter of time
before they explode again because of the
high transmissibility of the omicron
variant
joining us is journalist fabian kreshmer
in beijing fabian we know the government
tried to censor what residents of
shanghai were sharing about their
lockdown experiences so i'm curious to
what extent do people in beijing have a
sense of what they might be facing
yeah it depends um actually there's a
really wide spectrum some residents
especially the elderly they get their
information from the state media for
example they watch the evening news and
then um they get the impression that
everything is under control and they're
not really aware of the human suffering
of people in shanghai and then at the
other end of the spectrum you you have
the um youngish crowd who
uses a vpn software that's that's
the device that is needed to get around
the censorship here and they um follow
um international media they follow um
you know social media platform with
critical information and um they are
very well aware of um the suffering in
shanghai and they also know that this
could happen in beijing and most
residents that i talk to they're
somewhere in between and
they know to some degree what has
happened in shanghai and what
potentially also could happen here in
beijing but they chose also not to focus
too much on it and i think that's also
one way of coping with the situation
they don't want to anticipate the worst
uh case scenario that's certainly a very
human instinct so overall how on edge is
everybody there
yeah when the authorities first
announced that um omicron was spreading
here in the city there was a lot of
panic buying and um a really tense
situation um also something that i have
not really witnessed in the early days
of the pandemic really this time it felt
um yeah different more tense actually
and
now that has relaxed to some degree why
because um
we have not seen an exponential growth
of the
daily cases numbers we are at roughly 50
or 60 every day and
that is rather stable so there's no
panic and
the disruptions here of daily life
because of the restrictions they are
annoying they are also economically
damaging but um they are only really an
existential threat for a minority of
people to give you an idea that um here
the restaurants are closed they're only
open for takeout and delivery and we
basically have to get um tested i mean
really pcr tests every day um but we can
still go wherever we want and the people
who are really locked down sealed off um
is um so far really maybe several one
hundred thousands maximum
yeah which is a lot of people or very
little if you look at uh the entire
population of beijing do you have a
sense that officials learned from their
experience in shanghai and we won't be
seeing some of the more draconian
measures implemented in the capital
well the lesson that they drew from the
situation in shanghai um
is maybe different than uh many would
assume i mean um basically they thought
that um our um zero covet strategy is
working but it was not really
implemented radical and swiftly enough
by the authorities in shanghai so now
what the authorities here are doing is
they step in really very early um
as i said i mean several one hundred
thousands um
of people locked down in their
apartments with only 60 daily cases it
is
really quite early and
very radical so to speak and i get the
sense that some residents
speculate that um because beijing is a
political center also the center of
power that um the authorities cannot
afford to also lock down this really
symbolic city and um they have some
trust however if that's justified i
think probably it will be decided in the
in the coming weeks i mean definitely
everyday life is not really normal and
we have to embrace that it could get
worse how worse i don't know yet
fabian kreshmer we will definitely be
getting back to you on this again and
again it seems like china is intent on
this zero kovitch strategy thank you so
much
the counterpoint to what's happening in
china is what's happening in taiwan
the democracy is keen to show that it
will not infringe on citizen rights in
the way its authoritarian neighbor has
the government has relaxed quarantine
rules for overseas arrivals even as
covet cases rise the streets of taiwan
remain pretty normal but there's been a
renewed rush at vaccination sites as
people line up to get jabbed or boosted
and as taiwan's premiere explained the
government's shift he made some pointed
barbs at china's continued insistence on
a zero
approach
we will not lock down the country and
cities as cruelly as china
we are also not like some other
countries where they have no choice but
to live with the virus
we move step by step according to plan
and there's a rhythm to it
dw's joyce lee has more out of taipei
here in taiwan the omicron outbreak
started in april this week the number of
daily cases passed 20 000 for the first
time but unlike china the south route
island is moving away from the cereal
covert policy public opinion shifted
after taiwanese people saw what happened
in shanghai
according to the latest poll 60 percent
of taiwanese people now support living
with covert premier susan tang said
earlier this week that taiwan will not
lock down cities as cruelly as china he
also stressed that the government is
taking a gradual approach to resume
normal lives
out here on the street in taipei city is
business as usual but people are
generally cautious the biggest challenge
is the lack of rapid test kits
the government launched a rationing
system last week but can't meet demand
long queues are seen outside pharmacies
some people i spoke with queue up for 45
minutes but still left empty-handed
after coming under strong criticism the
health minister promised to make test
kits more available on the island
you